[Music]
welcome back to the showroom floor I'm
really excited to be here because now
I'm over in the customer magic zone and
it's really really cool but right now
I'm standing with Klaus who is a senior
engineer for IKEA and he's going to show
us one of the most popular demos in the
area there are crowds of people trying
to fight their way in right now hey back
up
I'm looking at you but so before you
actually show me how it works can you
tell me a little bit about how your team
developed this yeah sure so we assembled
a pretty small team that working working
and it's iterative fashion that's
dividing the work but close feedback
loops together with Google engineering
yeah we used a vision API product search
yes it's awesome
together with object detection that
we're trying out together with Google to
enhance the product offering from your
site and also you know try to work with
the customer experience on our site so
you'll see in the demo ok and then we
talked about how your team really
focused on working iteratively now I
heard a rumor that you all did this
whole thing in less than three weeks
that's very amazing yeah no fast paced
very short Sprint's that we did right so
you got to work with you mentioned some
Google engineers which is really cool
but you also you get to work for a
company that like really encourages and
gives you the space to try these ideas
so quickly like that how does that feel
like as a developer that's really good
that we we are empowered to do this kind
of exploration cases it sounds like a
dream yeah it's really ok so speaking of
dreams will you show me how this works
maybe on the horse right sure sure so
this is here we try to detect the object
yep and then it matches to arrange right
and then you can interact with it and it
will show you our mobile web page where
we can get more information and then
could you do like this stool yeah sure
so let's
it will recognize it and show direct
it's a yawning is stool and then we can
say it is that instead of taking that
little pencil you can walk around and
this is your pointer quick does it even
get like decorative items of course of
course so let's try this one out so you
see here I got directly this is so cheap
and it's a plant I can tell ya cuz it's
fake it's even called fake what do you
really yeah is that British perfect oh
my gosh I want one so badly this is a
really cool demo
I'm sorry understand now why there's a
crowd of people waiting to get back in
here so I want to thank you so much for
talking to me a fan for building that
thanks for having us now I'm so excited
I will be in the store pretty soon but
you're a great day and then thanks to
all of y'all for watching and we'll show
you some more cool things later
[Music]